si es un avance pero definitivamente
todavía no hay humo blanco en esas
negociaciones para el futuro acuerdo
comercial y la relación entre londres y
bruselas a partir del primero de enero
de 2021 eso es lo primero que hay que
decir las negociaciones siguen
estancadas en tres puntos fundamentales
en derechos de pesca la ayuda estatal y
la igualdad en las reglas es importante
entonces explicarles que la isla de
irlanda está dividida en dos una la
republica hace parte de la unión europea
y el norte de irlanda está en el reino
unido- para evitar que se revivan las
complejidades que puso fin al conflicto
y dio paso al acuerdo de paz del viernes
santo de 1998 entonces la unión europea
en el acuerdo break si se acordó que
habría un protocolo especial para
irlanda del norte para evitar instalar
la frontera física entonces habría que
poner una frontera dentro del reino
unido- que causaba problemas con los
unionistas en este país que no estaban
de acuerdo porque definitivamente
quebraría la unión lo que ha sucedido y
lo que se ha comprometido el gobierno es
a retirar esta polémica parte
de todas maneras las negociaciones están
estancadas